it's a huge talking point for socialists
and here's why because they've always
been held to the standard of well how
are you going to pay for it so modern
monetary theory is well we'll just
digitize or print the money well that
sounds like old failed monetary policy
but this is new and the idea is is that
as long as everybody understands that
mmm we can just print the money and if
we need the money we're gonna have to
tax everybody to death but we're not
gonna need the money so we'll just make
the money and then we'll spend the money
and that will help us make more money
modern monetary theory and if there's
inflation
we'll use price controls and we'll also
use taxes to make sure that people are
buying only the things that we want them
to buy this is total control of an
economy through a government through the
printing of dollars that's modern
monetary theory
[Music]
how afraid are you generally that we're
just gonna kind of keep giving away
these things that that the time the
calendar will keep marching and slowly
yeah we won't go in our cars we won't
leave our house suddenly walking your
dog will be a problem and you'll you
know it can only go in the backyard or
just like the endless cascade of things
that we can think of but I'm more
worried about the things that we can't
think of that they could come for so
here's this here's the worst part in the
book arguing with socialists yeah you
have a copy there open up chapter 6 yeah
yeah open it up to chapter 6 okay I
don't know if you if you saw that one
but it's how technology and modern
monetary theory can make socialism more
dangerous than ever
mm-hmm this is this was this was
assuming that the economic collapse
would come over a slow long period of
time that the economic collapse would
and joblessness would happen maybe
because of Technology the in that
chapter I outline what happens in that
situation where it's lots of joblessness
the first thing that happens is the
government needs to spend more money and
so they start to print more money
printed in the last few weeks more money
then we we digitized more money than we
could have printed in a year you
literally could not print that there's
not enough trees to print the amount of
money that we have just digitized in a
two or three week period so not about
their gold anymore it's not even about
the dollars because we can't print them
fast enough now we're just truly in a
sort of imaginary it's situation so it
is called it is called modern monetary
theory have you ever heard of it Dave I
haven't I'm a simple man this is a huge
no no no the most people don't know it
it's a huge talking point for socialists
and here's
because they've always been held to this
standard of well how are you going to
pay for it so modern monetary theory is
well we'll just digitize or print the
money well that sounds like old failed
monetary policy but this is new and the
idea is is that as long as everybody
understands that mm-hmm
we can just print the money and if we
need the money we're gonna have to tax
everybody to death but we're not gonna
need the money so we'll just make the
money and then we'll spend the money and
that will help us make more money modern
monetary theory and if there's inflation
we'll use price controls and we'll also
use taxes to make sure that people are
buying only the things that we want them
to buy this is total control of an
economy through a government through the
printing of dollars that's modern
monetary theory the Fed is doing it
right now but the UK Treasury the crown
just announced that they are using
Monaco modern monetary theory and they
are actually just printing the DA
they're at least admitting it we're
doing it as well in this chapter I
talked about when that starts the
government is going to know it needs
tech and tech will know it needs the
government and so the tech and the
government will start to work together
to monitor people because they'll need
to monitor and track etc etc the
coronavirus has made chapter six a
reality it is you asked me you know how
nervous are you I'm terrified that what
I wrote in chapter six is happening
right now okay so there's so much there
so so jumping from that which will sort
of lead us further into the book so how
much of this the situation that we're in
right now do you think was just because
our systems were collapsing in front of
us we were watching the medias system
collapse in front of us we were watching
academia collapse in front of us we were
watching the political establishment
collapse and that all of those collapses
and then you find a crisis that you can
throw in the middle of that lead to this
perfect stew where suddenly numbers
don't even mean anything and we have new
monetary policy okay so let me let me
answer it this way you know the the
Reichstag fire of course never let a
good crisis really correct
now the Germans said does let's separate
this from what we know let me give you
two aspects or two two answers on this
one the Germans said that that fire was
happening and then the the Nazis just
took advantage of it that's one version
the other version is no they started it
and they wanted it to burn and then they
used that fire so I don't think I don't
think that that is what happened here I
don't think anyone started this fire I
don't think that while I do believe that
this did come from bats that were you
know the specimens were collected by the
Chinese and brought to that lab it was
not released intentionally it was sloppy
so nobody created this crisis and then
it's a series of events that just spiral
out of control but I do believe at some
point somebody came in and went you know
this whole thing is melting down anyway
this might be a good time just up pull
the plug I do think that's a possibility
man we just have the craziest people in
charge yeah it's weird because we all
sort of become conspiracy theorists
theorists and then it's like well what's
really a conspiracy not because what
you're saying is it's not that it's some
coordinated thing necessarily
but events transpire and feed off each
other and next thing you know here we
are and you not only have events feed
off each other you do have bad actors
for instance China is now telling France
we can help you out all you want but you
have to take our 5g
systems will give you all the masks that
you need but will only sell them to you
if you do so you have bad actors doing
that and I do think that there are those
who are in global positions be them
people that are you know in high tech or
in high finance or governments that do
want a different system that don't
believe in the system of the West and
they would like to use an opportunity to
their advantage I don't think it's a
conspiracy theory to think that people
you know actually believe don't let a
crisis go to waste especially since many
people in positions of power have been
saying it out loud recently you know if
you look at what the Fabian socialist
did in World War one we wouldn't have
gone to war if there weren't a group of
people that were saying this is actually
gonna work to our advantage we should go
to world war because we can change the
world closer to our heart's desire
that's what they did then and I think it
it plays some role here so it's
interesting because all of this actually
is sort of directly related to why
you're constantly arguing with
socialists but before we get into the
book specifically just one more thing on
this generally what do you make of the
role or the state of media right now I
know you and I are in agreement on just
watching mainstream media collapse and
in many and in many ways it should but
like just in the last couple days this
insane New York Times story that's sort
of defended Biden because there's no
evidence even though that wasn't the
standard they held Brett Kavanaugh to or
or a million other examples I can give
lately of just you know Corona related
nonsense and you know two months ago
it's not going to be a problem now
they're they're screaming fire I mean
all of this because that's another piece
of this that I think has just run Ram
shot basically across everybody and
nobody knows there's a trust right now
so it's a crisis of trust in almost
everything if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell